one episode of ted lasso
29 minutes
36 shots of apple products
[Music]
that's about 1.24 apple products per
minute
over the last month i've analyzed 74
apple tv plus episodes or
about 2600 minutes worth of shows but
why do this to myself well i was struck
by how heavy-handed some of the apple
product placement is and by how likable
ted lasso is nice in the 74 episodes i
watched there were over 700 apple
products shown over 300 iphones 120
macbooks and around 40 pairs of airpods
apple declined to comment on this than
any of the reporting in this video
various writers and producers for apple
tv plus shows did not return my emails
now apple product placement isn't new
the company's products have been showing
up in tv and movies for decades what is
new is that it's now on apple's own
proverbial turf and terms now that tech
giants control their own streaming
services they're able to subject tv
lovers to a whole new type of product
integration after consulting product
placement experts and engaging in what
can only be described as a punishing
watch process i found that not only is
apple strategy just way over the top in
terms of quantity of product shown on
screen but it's also
very strategic
before i got to watching i had to teach
myself how to effectively watch for
product placement so i spoke with
various experts including crystal
antonia russell and i'm a professor of
marketing at the graziadio school of
business at pepperdine university dr
russell is one of the longest running
experts on product placement studying it
for more than 20 years now
to the untrained eye product placement
is just that a product placed in a scene
but if you're dr russell or trying to
watch like her you're looking for some
key elements i usually
count three dimensions
visual
the level of visual the prominence in
the visual the placement of the visual
on the screen
audio
what's being said about the brand if
it's being discussed he wants us to open
presents and spend all day together on
face time and the last one is plot
connection and plot connection includes
any relevance to the plot but also the
characters in their stories so with
those three parameters in mind i've
analyzed five shows all the way through
every episode including ted lasso mythic
quest morning show trying and defending
jacob experts watching for product
placement use a handy guide for
determining where a product appears in
frame and so we usually split the screen
into nine quadrants nine little squares
inevitably viewers attentions are much
more on the middle quadrant and so a
brand that's actually more centered is
going to get a lot more attention than
the brand that's on the periphery
and you guessed it in my analysis apple
products appeared most often in section
5. those scenes typically started with
them on the periphery near section 7 8
and 9. based on my analysis ted lasso
had the most product sightings per
minute over 14 episodes apple gadgets
and services were spotted around 230
times
in the episode mentioned earlier nearly
half the sightings were in the center of
the screen not far behind was the
morning show over 10 episodes in its
first season apple products were spotted
around 250 times though the episodes are
twice as long in the episode with the
most sightings 12 of the 33 placements
were centered while mythic quest trying
and defending jacob didn't have nearly
as many integrations apple products and
services were frequently right in the
middle
audio placements are more subtle but can
be just as powerful
so the audio can be anything and in fact
if a sound like a jingle or logo or a
you know male kind of signal
is making people think about a brand
that also counted as a product placement
at the brand placement reference to the
brand in the consumer's mind and ted
lasso some of it's pretty obvious yeah
just a little note to myself tell me to
buy apple stock we are now sharing an
icloud account
and the characters of mythicquest and
trying love to
hello it's not working i'm gonna go
facetime my kids
no
no no
this is an audio facetime you see me now
and our last and most subtle of the
product placement dimensions plot
connection think of apple gadgets as
literal plot devices they're being used
to move stories forward and develop
characters take this example from ted
lasso when after much indecision ted
commits to signing his divorce papers
from beginning to end of this storyline
the iphone was involved acting as a
connective tissue between ted and his
soon-to-be ex-wife finally he even uses
the iphone camera to scan the contract
and send it back to the lawyer and then
there's this one scene in trying where
the leading characters jason and nikki
are gathered around a macbook to await
an update on their child adoption
process or in mythic quest during their
pandemic episode airpods are used not
only to connect nearly every character
but they're on screen for about 18
minutes of the 24 minute episode and of
course plot is attached to characters
most consumers when they watch a show
especially tv series where to develop
these sort of
life-like relationships which are called
parasocial relationships with the
characters they feel like they get to
know them and so if you see the
character associated with a product in a
in a tv series or in a story your
feelings and attitudes toward the
character are going to transfer over to
that brand my analysis showed that these
likable main characters are the ones
most frequently shown with apple
products in ted lasso over the course of
14 episodes rebecca welton a character
whose arc bends from antagonist to ted
lasso ally is most often seen with apple
products around 70 times while ted has
spotted nearly 60 times with various
apple products
jason and nikki the similarly likable
and funny leads in trying are seen in
every episode of season 2 with iphones
in the morning show the two leading
ladies bradley and alex lead the pack
with iphone sightings each was seen with
an iphone around 30 times in 10 episodes
according to previous reports apple
specifically limits villains and bad
guys from appearing with its products
apple declined to comment on those
reports but i found lots of evidence of
that myself
in mythic quest joe a power hungry and
manipulative main character who is at
one point described as conservative is
seen almost exclusively with an
unbranded macbook also in that airpod
episode her hair was conspicuously
covering her ears in almost every shot
in the morning show bradley's absentee
father when first introduced is shown
with an unbranded flip phone
and in defending jacob leonard patz one
of the main characters uses an android
and also as a pedophile charged with
murder
so how does this all affect you and me
the viewers if a product placement is
effective your attitude will be more
positive
after watching an episode than before so
we measure pre and we measure posts and
we compare that
but really the sort of the best is to
see like well are they gonna buy a pepsi
and that's really hard to do in the case
of apple you've probably already bought
the product now you just like this guy
so much you might buy it again